[Музика]
Я думаю, насправді це було дуже
важливе рішення для багатьох людей
є 20 мільйонів клієнтів
приватний банк
це найбільший банк в україні
значною мірою люди роблять самі
звичайно це виправдано і хвилюється
Я думаю, що рішення так
національний банк уряд ам
зустрілися на вихідних
потрібний товар у важкій ситуації
Ситуація в банку була економічна
це може вирішити проблеми самостійно
більше не вирішити
в такому випадку, якщо банк
краще сказати, що система є
націоналізація банку єдина
правильний крок і це вчора
було виконано
Національний банк в даний час лідирує дуже
глибокі реформи галузі за в
вже залучено понад 80 банків
закрито або обробляється
щоразу, коли банки виконують вимоги
регулятори, тобто Національний банк
тоді треба вирішувати
що відбувається з банком і ім
справа приватного банку, який був
інтернаціоналізація
Я думаю, що це потрібно добре повідомити
і я не думаю, що є якісь причини
для занепокоєння, тому що зараз з
приватні банки дуже сильні
сильний господар в україні
є тепер одна з моїх надій
також немає нової невизначеності в
ринок приходить і, так би мовити, the
останній також незавершений крок
реформа банківського сектору зараз також
може бути виконано
це останній крок в одному
процес реформування два з половиною роки
триває багато банків, які просто не витримують
були здоровими в контексті
вирішив з огляду на поточну ситуацію
приватний банк також не був здоровим
так це може бути ця вимога до капіталу
від до 150 млрд. грн
було визначено, що ми знаємо
ще ні, що точно буде зараз
також саме місце
не закривати
тому держава має втрутитися за мене
насправді це трохи так
знак того, що ми дійсно скоро
знаходяться в кінці цього процесу очищення
і лише справді чисті розчинники
та ефективні інститути, тобто банки
залишилося менше ніж
100 із 180 інститутів раніше
два з половиною роки
Тому для мене це більше свого роду
кінець, ніж початок нового
королева сусі, я ні